(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar de como funciona
a venda do imóvel que você arrematou de
forma parcelada em leilão judicial.
Lá no módulo 2, a gente falou da
venda do imóvel financiado em leilão extrajudicial e
a gente falou da figura do interveniente quitante,
que pode ser um banco, que pode ser
até o mesmo banco que o arrematante tem
o financiamento, se for o interesse do comprador,
ou pode ser um outro banco.
Aqui em leilão judicial, vamos ver como funciona,
então.
Venda do imóvel parcelado em leilão judicial.
Quando você parcela o imóvel em leilão judicial,
a gente acabou de ver que não tem
banco envolvido nesse parcelamento.
Esse parcelamento vai ser feito direto com o
Poder Judiciário e a garantia vai ser uma
hipoteca judicial que vai ser registrada na matrícula
daquele imóvel.
Então, como é que você vai vender esse
imóvel?
Você vai precisar, primeiro, liberar essa hipoteca judicial.
Para liberar a hipoteca judicial, vai ter que
pagar o saldo restante em aberto daquele parcelamento.
Como pagar isso?
Você vai fazer um contrato de promessa de
compra e venda, estipulando um sinal suficiente para
quitar o saldo em aberto e esse sinal
suficiente para quitar o saldo em aberto vai
ser o necessário para quitar todo o parcelamento
e requerer a baixa da hipoteca judicial para
o juiz.
O juiz vai determinar a baixa da hipoteca
judicial, o arrematante vai levar essa ordem até
o cartório de registro de imóveis competente, o
cartório vai realizar a baixa e, aí sim,
o imóvel vai ficar livre para ser transferido
para o nome do comprador.
Se for uma compra à vista, o comprador
vai fazer ali com o vendedor, que é
o arrematante, uma escritura pública de compra e
venda e depois vai registrar o imóvel em
seu nome.
O lucro vai ser o valor da venda
menos o total pago que corresponde à entrada,
aos outros custos e o saldo devedor que
será quitado.
Se, por acaso, o comprador quiser recorrer a
um financiamento para a compra desse imóvel, ele
também vai ter que pagar um sinal suficiente
para liberar lá, quitar o parcelamento em aberto,
liberar a hipoteca judicial e, depois disso, ser
finalizado o financiamento na instituição financeira que o
comprador desejar.